>>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome Bruno
Oliveira and Adam Powell.
[ Applause ]
>>Bruno Oliveira: My name is Bruno Oliveira,
and I work in the Android Developer Relations
team.
I'm based in South America, and my mission
is to work with developers to get very high-quality
applications on Google Play.
>>Adam Powell: And I'm Adam Powell.
I work in Mountain View, California, on the
Android Framework team.
>>Bruno Oliveira: All right.
Thank you very much for coming to our session.
So we're going to talk about building user
interfaces that work across several platform
versions.
So, by the way, if I want to mention this
session on the social media, those are the
hashtags.
Before I begin, just a quick show of hands.
How many of you are developing Android applications?
Oh, duh.
How many of you are developing Android applications
that work only on a single platform release,
say, only for Jelly Bean or only for Ice Cream
Sandwich?
All right.
A few of you.
How many of you are targeting, let's say,
two or three major platform releases.
Okay.
That's more of you.
>>Adam Powell: That's great.
Hmm, that's really too easy, though.
Who's developing all the way back to, say,
Cupcake, maybe even earlier.
Anyone?
Wow, that's a lot of hands.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Very nice.
>>Adam Powell: That's great.
So why is this important?
>>Bruno Oliveira: That's a great question.
Why is this so important?
Why can't I care only about the latest version
of Android?
Adam, I don't know, what do you think?
>>Adam Powell: Maybe there are other versions
out there.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Others versions?
Really just show of hands, who has a device
with the latest version of Android.
Oh, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
>>Bruno Oliveira: Told you.
>>Adam Powell: We're set to go.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Everybody has --
>>Adam Powell: Everybody can go home; right?
Yeah, I think that we might actually have
a problem with our sampling.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Our sample is bad you think?
>>Adam Powell: Well, I think it's biased just
a little bit.
A little bit different.
Okay.
So who has parents running an Ice Cream Sandwich
or newer device.
Anyone?
Oh, wow.
That's more than I expected, actually.
Gingerbread moms, anyone?
Yes.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Froyo moms?
All right.
>>Adam Powell: Okay.
>>Bruno Oliveira: So why can't I care only
about the latest version of Android; right?
So yeah, that's definitely a better sampling
method.
If you've been developing for Android for
more than one day, chances are you're familiar
with this particular pie chart; right.
As you can see, the world is not exactly made
of ice cream out there yet.
So any application that's seriously considering
targeting most users should work on at least
Froyo, Gingerbread, Ice Cream Sandwich, and
Jelly Bean.
But there are developers, and they are among
us, who look at this chart and they are scared.
And they say that's difficult.
One thing I learned in the last 48 hours is
that jumping from a moving Zeppelin and landing
on top of Moscone center is difficult.
That stuff is easy.
[ Laughter ]
>>Adam Powell: Right.
This is actually fairly easy to do by comparison.
We're going to show you how just to make sure
that your user interface adapts correctly
across several platform versions.
It doesn't involve any extreme sports.
Don't worry.
>>Bruno Oliveira: For those of you who don't
like pie charts, don't worry.
As you can see, most of this presentation
is not in fact a pie chart.
Enough philosophy for now.
Let's start -- let's talk about some naive
approaches to multiversioning your Android
user interface.
It's worth mentioning that most of the approaches
we're going to mention here are all valid
to some degree.
And the only -- our point is that they should
not be taken to the extremes that we're going
to show you.
So with that warning, let's move on to the
first naive approach.
Some developers avoid evolution completely.
They just stick to the good old stuff, forget
anything about the new stuff; right?
It's already an improvement over what we would
have, say, 60 years ago.
But then it looks like their app is stuck
inside.
Because you open that up in Ice Cream Sandwich
and then it just looks exactly like it did
on Cupcake or almost at least.
So, be sure, you can say, yeah, but that's
because my app is consistent, consistency
is important.
But that's only because it's consistently
obsolete everywhere.
[ Laughter ]
>>Bruno Oliveira: Needless to say, that's
not a great idea.
Evolution is a must.
Now, there are some -- moving on, there are
some developers that know evolution is a good
thing.
But they are somehow fascinated with the concept
of multiple APK and they think that that's
a solution for everything, so they have one
for APK for Cupcake, one for Eclair, one for
Froyo, and maybe one for that odd device that
your boss is going to be using.
But, again, I'm not saying here that multiple
APK is a universally bad approach.
All I'm saying is it should not be abused
to the point that you have one separate APK
for each platform version.
Right, Adam?
>>Adam Powell: That's right.
This can really be a workable approach for
handling the divide between, say, Gingerbread
and Ice Cream Sandwich, where we had a whole
ton of changes in UX, especially when holo
came into the picture.
But we really don't recommend getting too
much more granular than that outside of some
serious edge cases.
You might consider, like, large versus small
screen if certain business cases allow for
it.
But, in general, you want to try and keep
things mostly together.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Now, some developers know
they should try and have one APK as much as
possible.
But they still write fully separate layout
and code for each version of Android.
While some degree of that is probably okay,
if you have -- if you get to a point where
you have different layout and code for each
major platform of Android, then you're probably
making things more complicated than you should.
So we don't recommend going crazy with this.
Actually, we don't recommend going crazy at
all in general.
>>Adam Powell: Right.
So taken to an extreme, this really isn't
much different than abusing multi-APK.
You're just cramming everything into the same
package.
You still have the same level of duplication
in practice that you have to maintain.
So when you split into separate resources
and code paths for different versions, it's
important to be really tactical about it.
So what are some ways that we can do that?
>>Bruno Oliveira: I'm glad you asked.
So let's stop (indiscernible).
So I think at this point, we probably leveled
up to a level 2 multiversioner.
So let's go over some basic multiversioning
skills.
There's a pretty common pattern called the
parallel activity pattern.
It's a quick and easy way to launch a different
activity depending on the platform version.
In this example here, we're detecting whether
we are running ICS or above.
If so, we're launching this shiny, cool activity;
right.
If not, then we're launching this legacy activity.
Now, this is a good approach when your activity
really, really depends a lot on the newer
platform features and you want to have a decent
fallback for the other versions.
Now, this should only be used when you have
to cross a major platform boundary, like pre
and post ICS.
Because if you have too many branches there,
things can start getting complicated pretty
fast.
Speaking about complications, sometimes when
developers implement a certain feature on
multiple platform versions, they write separate
classes that are mostly identical code except
for a few lines.
Now, this is -- essentially, this gets you
to a situation where it's impossible to simultaneously
maintain your code and your sanity.
You have to choose.
So this is not a good idea.
Now, there is no shame in using an if.
An if is a great thing.
And there is no shame in using it.
You can do that and still be in good standing
with developer society.
By the way, if you are worried that those
constants are going to break on the older
platform versions because there was no such
thing as Gingerbread in Froyo; right?
So great, that's exactly the sort of thing
that you should worry about.
But in this case, it's okay, because they
all get compiled to a pure number.
So it's not going to break in older versions.
>>Adam Powell: Specifically, these are the
build dot OS SDK versions that you can refer
to.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Exactly.
So our first advice is don't be afraid of
if.
Our second advice, that said, is be afraid
of if.
If you suddenly start to see those code branches
get too big, then we probably need a better
approach; right?
>>Adam Powell: Mm-hmm.
>>Bruno Oliveira: This is what we're going
to see next.
Let's talk about being lazy; right?
Laziness is probably one of the earliest human
inventions.
It probably even predates fire.
Human beings were being lazy long before they
invented anything else.
All throughout history, it's been a solution
to many of the world's toughest problems.
So this is one of those cases.
So we're not going to use laziness itself.
We're going to use lazy loading.
Adam, how can we use this kind of laziness
in our favor in this case.
>>Adam Powell: A couple years ago I wrote
a post for the Android developer's blog that
sort of details this idea.
So we start off by defining an abstract class
or interface describing what the application
wants to do.
And then we write implementations of that
interface for each platform version that layer
us on the new functionality as it becomes
available.
So we can use a simple factoring method or
a similar mechanism to get the right implementation
for the platform version we're running on
and then the calling code within the app doesn't
have to care about version differences anymore.
So here's a simple example.
We've declared an abstract class that represents
a few higher-level things that our app wants
to be able to do.
And then we have this simple base implementation.
It can do the job even if it's not really
fancy.
This is our fallback for older devices.
Sometimes you might just want to drop functionality
that you can't reasonably emulate or back
port.
And it's okay if some of these compatibility
implementations just end up being stubs or
no ops if there's really nothing more reasonable
that you can do.
But on a later version of the platform, we
can layer on additional -- or additional features
that enhance the user experience for those
people running on newer versions of Android.
Note that we're calling back into the super
class implementation over here in our contrived
example.
This can be a great way to just layer extra
functionality on your base behavior, reduce
extra duplication, especially if we're not
just replacing it with something entirely
new.
So a simple series of version checks makes
sure that we can construct the right version
behind the scenes.
And then the rest of our code can remain ignorant
of any and all version differences.
And for those of you wondering or anyone who's
gone source-diving in the Android support
library, this is actually the same tactic
that we use there.
There's really nothing magic going on in that
library.
This is how we've written all the compatibility
shims that we've made available so far.
And you'll notice that this idea of these
really highly focused, isolated cases of layering
on more advanced functionality when it's available
is present through all of these approaches
to multiversioning that we're talking about
today.
If you factor out all of these things into
smaller, more isolated components within your
app, it stays a whole lot easier to maintain
than trying to use some big overarching approach
that involves a lot of duplication.
Okay.
So enough about laziness for now.
Let's talk about something that's not so lazy.
Well, it -- actually, it does a whole lot
of work for you.
It does let you still be lazy, though.
So we're, of course, talking about the Android
developer's best friend, the resource system.
So a great tool for you to be aware of, if
you're not already, is the version qualifier
for your resource directories.
The naming scheme looks a lot like this.
So you can use this to offer alternate versions
of your layouts, your drawables, styles, and
way more than that, depending on what platform
version the device is currently running.
But, like everything else that we're talking
about today, it's important to use this in
moderation.
Again, if you take it to an extreme, you get
a lot of XML duplication, which is just as
bad as other code duplication.
So what are some strategies we can use to
avoid some of that?
>>Bruno Oliveira: So the first strategy is
using Boolean resources.
So a Boolean resource is something as simple
as the name implies.
They're actually tons of fun, because they
can be true, but they can also be false.
[ Laughter ]
>>Bruno Oliveira: The real point, of course,
is not being true or false.
It's that they can be given -- their values
can be given at run time by the resource system.
So this means that they can actually vary
according to the device configuration, like
screen size, or in our case, the platform
version.
So, for example, this is a file called bools.xml,
and it's in the values-V14 directory.
It's defining two Boolean resources.
So one of them is called post ICS, and the
other one is called pre-ICS.
Now, because this is in the values-V14 directory,
these are only going to apply to devices running
Ice Cream Sandwich or above.
Now, likewise, we have the bools.xml file
in our unqualified values directory.
This one has the opposite value, so this is
only going to apply when the device is running
a version of Android that's prior to Ice Cream
Sandwich.
Now, of course, you can use Boolean resources
directly like this, using get Boolean; right?
There is nothing wrong with that, and that
might be useful in some cases.
But the most interesting thing about Boolean
resources -- and it's not that they can be
true or false -- is that you can actually
enable or disable components according to
the platform version, like this.
For example, app widgets; right?
So who here has written an app widget?
Lots of people have written app widgets.
I did, too.
So an app widget is essentially just a broadcast
receiver with some special data in it; right?
So if you have written one, you know it looks
like this.
The point is, if you do it just like that,
it's going to look the same and behave the
same for all the platform versions.
But what if we wanted to provide a different
version for, say, devices running ICS or above?
>>Adam Powell: Can we use a Boolean resource?
>>Bruno Oliveira: Yes, we can.
Glad you asked.
Exactly.
So we have to define two app widgets.
First, let's define the pre-ICS one.
So for the pre-ICS, we just set Android enabled
to bool/pre-ICS.
So this means that it's true if and only if
we're running on a pre-ICS device.
Likewise, we're going to do the same for post
ICS.
So for my post ICS widget, I set Android enabled
to bool post ICS.
And that's going to be true if and only if
I'm running on a device that's running ICS
or above.
Both widgets, of course, go into my applications
manifest.
And the magic of this is that the correct
one is going to be automatically activated
depending on the platform version that you're
running on.
But that's for app widgets.
What if you wanted to have a fallback like
that but for an activities user interface.
In this case, what you need is a UI fallback,
which is a technique that you can use when
there are certain parts of your layout that
you would like to do differently depending
on the platform version that you're running
on.
For example, in this example where we're going
to use this technique to present the new and
awesome switch widgets on ICS; right?
And then on the same application, same layout,
we're going to display the good old classic
check box on the older versions; right?
So how do we do that?
Well, we could do that using, like, two separate
layout files.
Everybody knows how to do that.
But that would be no fun; right?
The whole point is to have a single main layout
file and then pull bits and pieces from the
other files as appropriate.
Here's what our main layout file would look
like.
These comments in green are the parts that
don't depend on the platform version, for
example, that text view; right.
But for the part that does depend on the platform
version, we're using layout include.
We're pulling another layout by its ID, but
the desserts ID.
So this means that we can supply different
versions of that included layout that's going
to depend on the version that we're running.
So how do we do that?
We place two different versions of our desserts.xml
file.
One of them is in the layout directory, unqualified;
right?
And the other one is in the layout-V11 directory.
So if I'm running on ICS or above, it's the
right-hand side that's going to kick in, so
with the switches.
If I'm running on a device that's pre-ICS,
it's the left-hand side that's going to kick
in, and it's going to run with the check boxes.
So that just gets plugged in into the right
place in our main layout because of the layout
include.
One thing to note on the code is that you
should always be aware of whether you're dealing
with a switch or a check box.
You could branch on top of the version and
then cache to the appropriate classes, but
that's difficult.
Instead, you can just realize that they both
derive from compound button and just do it
like that, which is much easier, of course.
In all cases, remember that this trick is
not just limited to widget fallbacks.
So layout includes are actually a very powerful
tool, and they can always be used when you
have sections of your layout that should be
different depending on device configuration.
So platform version, screen size, anything
else that you can describe with a device configuration,
you can use layout includes.
All right.
So let's move on to another very important
topic.
So we're developers, right, so we are focused
on making stuff that works.
We like stuff that works.
But legend has it that users also care about
looks.
Go figure.
So let's talk about how we can make sure that
your themes work across platform versions.
So in this way, you can make your app look
great, regardless of what release you're running
on.
So, Adam, how can we do that?
>>Adam Powell: All right.
I'm glad you asked.
On a Nexus device today, you have basically
four themes that users might see on a regular
basis.
And in the long run, we'd really like to get
this down to two.
But there will always be a few legacy apps
that users really don't want to let go of.
By the way, creating any sort of more modern
replacement for those that are still floating
around, great opportunity.
There's also the device default themes which,
on a Nexus device, they just simply alias
to the holo themes.
So we're going to mostly talk about those
for now.
But a theme, really, at its core is a bundle
of defaults.
It's just a style that's applied at the context
level, after all.
It defines the default look and feel for each
type of view.
But more importantly, it provides a point
of indirection that you can use in your apps.
Your layouts probably have a whole lot of
hard-coded metrics here and there, like text
sizes, paddings, margins, so on and so forth.
And this is fine.
But the theme also has a bunch of defaults
that you can query using the syntax shown
here.
(indiscernible) ops makes sure that you're
using the metrics that the rest of the system
does, making your app feel more like a first-class
citizen.
But between -- Whoops.
Too quick.
But between some elements that you query from
the theme and other elements that are unique
to your app, it can get really repetitive
if you use the same value over and over.
And this is where it becomes a good idea to
define some of your own custom styles that
you can apply to views.
So you've always got a base to build on when
you're defining a style, especially if you're
going to redefine what a default button style
is on a custom theme, so on and so forth.
You always want to declare a parent for your
styles so that that way you always inherit
all of the defaults that are there that you
may not really care about.
But the problem, of course, is that holo and
device default didn't exist before Honeycomb
and ICS, respectively.
So how do we write our apps so that it looks
like this, depending on what kind of device
that we're running on?
The key is in which parent you declare in
your custom styles and themes.
So before Honeycomb, you'll want to base your
apps theme on the legacy theme or theme.light.
And after Honeycomb, you may want to use the
holo variants instead.
So how can we do that?
And, really, the same goes for the widget
styles.
The simplest way to do this that comes to
mind for most developers is to just redeclare
the styles in a resource overlay for V11;
right?
Well, of course, that gets into the same problem
of duplication again.
A better way is to declare a base style that
varies by version and then keep your main
customizations in a style that derives from
that instead.
So you get this simple declaration here to
declare a parent that will be selected at
run time.
And you can keep all the customizations that
are unique to your app in one place rather
than duplicate them.
And by doing this, we've separated out what's
unique about different Android versions, and
we're targeting -- or the different Android
versions that we're targeting and separating
those from how our app differs from that base.
So, if a theme is just a big ball of metadata
about defaults, can we create our own attributes
that we can query from later?
Maybe this will be helpful for us.
And the answer, of course, is that, yes, we
can.
This is especially helpful when there are
no attributes available in newer versions
of the platform, but that they didn't exist
before that.
So you can create a simple shim attribute
of your own in one place and get the right
behavior everywhere.
So here's a quick example of adapting the
selectable item background attribute that
was introduced in Honeycomb across multiple
platform versions.
By convention, we always declare theme attributes
in a file named attrs.xml and the res values
directory, and then we assign values to the
new attribute in our apps theme declarations.
If we're using the tactic from earlier, with
a base theme that varies by platform version,
then we can put declarations that bridge the
version gaps like this in the base themes
rather than the theme that actually declares
our app's own customizations.
So there are still going to be device-specific
skins out there to consider when you build
your UI.
So when is it appropriate to use each theme?
So as of Ice Cream Sandwich, holo is a stable
base, you can always count on it being there
and we have designed it to be easy to work
with.
And we kind of like it.
So device default is a little bit less predictable,
but this is how you can integrate with all
the various device skins if you're willing
to query the theme for just about everything
that you do.
There are very few assumptions that you can
make here, but it can give you a very native-looking
experience if you're willing to work with
it.
When it comes to the layout and structure
of your content, on the other hand, following
the guidelines on the Android design site
is still a really great place to start, regardless
of what theme you're using.
With very few exceptions, you should always
try and keep structure and interaction patterns
consistent across different themes and versions
of the platform.
Bruno, can you give us some tips about some
of those cases?
>>Bruno Oliveira: Sure.
So let's talk a little bit about the support
library and beyond.
So one of the great tools -- they are great
tools to help you keep a -- consistent user
experience patterns across multiple platform
versions.
So these will greatly simplify your work.
>>Adam Powell: That's right.
And in just a few weeks, we're about to make
available some more tools that will encapsulate
a lot of this stuff that we've been talking
about today for the commonly used components,
things like the selectable item background
that we mentioned.
So app compat is a new addition to the support
library to join the existing v4 and v13 components
that you're probably already familiar with.
While the parts of the support library that
we've already released provide this abstract
box of tools for you to work with for building
your multiversioned apps, app compat elements
are designed to help you follow the Android
design guidelines across those multiple platform
versions.
>>Bruno Oliveira: One of the components that
the support library can help you with is fragments.
Fragments are modular units of composition
within an activity.
So multiple fragments can be combined together
to form a single layout.
And they're actually a great way to manage
user interfaces that work on phones and tablets.
Now, fragments are not an ICS feature; right?
They are so useful that we've made them available
all the way back to Honeycomb.
So -- oh, no.
Actually (indiscernible) for you.
So Adam.
>>Adam Powell: Well, so what do we do?
Well, I mean, everybody likes Froyo; right?
So as you already know, if you've been using
the support library, you can use fragments
on previous versions as well with the back-ported
version that we've provided.
All you have to do is add the support library
to your project and import the correct classes.
Then you proceed as you would with a regular
fragment.
>>Bruno Oliveira: For example, here we're
defining our own fragment class.
So this is the same as we would do if there
were no support library at all.
We simply derive it from fragment; right?
And then we override the appropriate methods
as we wish.
Now, adding fragments to a layout is also
no different than you would do without the
support library.
So it's perfectly transparent in this case.
So this is an example of adding fragments
to your layout using XML.
So remember that you can also do that from
code using fragment transactioners if you
prefer.
One thing to be careful about is that you
have to derive your activity from fragment
activity and not activity; right?
So this is specific to the support library.
So this is one of the few places where the
transparency is not 100%.
>>Adam Powell: You've got something.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Yes, by the way, I think
it's time that we talked to you about --
>>Adam Powell: Notifications.
>>Bruno Oliveira: -- notifications, yes.
So, as devices get more advanced, the complexity
of things they can do with notifications increase
a lot.
But, fundamentally, they are just a way to
tell the user that something is happening
right now or is about to happen and it's something
that they actually care about.
So this last part is actually pretty important.
The user has to care about the -- yeah, about
the event that you are telling him.
So before Honeycomb, notifications were somewhat
limited; right?
So this is what you would probably see as
far as code is concerned.
So you can discreet your notifications directly
and then set parameters and happened it off
to the manager.
Naturally, you can use it for simple cases
but after Honeycomb, this became a lot more
interesting.
So we introduced this notification builder
that helps developers create them.
Notification builder is a builder that actually
provides notification for you based on the
settings that you provide by calling its methods.
It is definitely a lot easier than building
it by hand.
So I like this notification builder thing,
so it makes me really happy.
But then I realize it's only for APIs 11 and
above so that makes me sad.
>>Adam Powell: What if I tell you this is
also in the support library.
>>Bruno Oliveira: I'm happy again.
>>Adam Powell: Import it and it works in the
most common use cases.
>>Bruno Oliveira: What are the changes in
Jelly Bean?
So let's be concrete about it.
We are developers.
According to a recent study the notification
builder in Jelly Bean is approximately 217%
more awesome than the one we had before.
[ Laughter ]
>>Bruno Oliveira: Those are very reliable
and serious numbers.
So this is -- for instance, it includes methods
like add action, which you would be able to
see if the screen shot was in front of it.
Actions on the notification.
Like answer and ignore.
And also, another pretty cool feature about
notifications is you can use styles.
So you can set the style using the set style
method and it comes with a certain predefined
styles that encapsulate most of the commonly
used types of notifications.
>>Adam Powell: Unfortunately, the naming here
might imply otherwise.
But the styles really do just refer to these
different styles of notifications and not
actually resource styles in terms of the resource
system.
>>Bruno Oliveira: So this is what the big
text style looks like.
We have a title and a large amount of text
under it.
It can be for, say, an email snippet, right?
Then this is what the inbox style looks like,
when you have a content title and snippets
for several items.
This is the big picture style.
Title, details, and guess what?
>>Adam Powell: Big picture.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Yes, exactly.
And there are several other new features but
we can't cover them all here because we don't
have time.
It's definitely worth taking a look if you
are at users notifications anyway.
Now, sadly, the new Jelly Bean notification
features are not yet in the support library.
So if you want to take advantage of this right
away and be backwards compatible, you have
to do a branch.
So if you can detect whether you are running
Jelly Bean or not.
If you are, just use a notification builder
natively.
And else, just use the notification comeback
builder in the support library.
Fall back to the support library.
Hopefully one day it's going to become easier.
>>Adam Powell: One day pretty soon.
>>Bruno Oliveira: One day pretty soon, yes.
Another important point, be careful when creating
notifications, icon consistency.
On Froyo and older devices, you would have
white over a black background.
This is what a notification icon would look
like.
On Gingerbread, they would be gray over a
transparent background.
And then on Honeycomb, they would be white
over a transparent background.
And for each of those, you have to supply
the versions for all the screen densities
possible, right?
>>Adam Powell: That's way too many icons.
Is there a tool or something we could use
for this?
>>Bruno Oliveira: Maybe.
Maybe it's on the next slide.
Oh, joy, it is on the next slide.
So surprise, surprise, there is actually a
tool that helps you with that.
It's called the Android asset studio.
It can be found on that URL up there.
So it generates the icons for you.
It's pretty nice to have in your toolbox.
Check it out if you haven't used it before.
Now, let's move on to another very important
topic.
The action bar.
So Adam, can you tell us why the action bar
is such an important topic?
>>Adam Powell: The action bar provides a consistent
way for the user to navigate and perform within
your application.
You can make up your own way to navigate and
perform actions.
Anyone who has used an modern Android application
is probably familiar with a bar already.
So in the interest of making your app easy
to learn, there's a good chance your app should
use it too.
Most times when someone calls an app intuitive,
what they are really say is it works like
something else that I'm already familiar with.
So you really want to make use of that wherever
you can.
Action bar has two parts.
Navigation, which is usually tab spinners,
the up button and such, and actions.
Actions are divided between the action buttons
that are visible that are surfaced on the
bar itself and the action overflow that's
behind that little three dot button right
there.
And remember the FIT rule from the Android
design guide.
Anytime that an action is frequent, important,
or typical it should be on screen whether
that's in the action bar or not.
Anytime that it's not, then you should think
about tucking it away someplace that's maybe
not taking up that valuable screen real estate
all the time.
The overflow is one way to do that.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Wait, I've heard some rumors,
they may be rumors, but the action bar seems
to not be available before Honeycomb?
>>Adam Powell: Really?
>>Bruno Oliveira: Yes.
If that's true, what can we do?
>>Adam Powell: If you are running on a pre-Honeycomb
device, you can implement your own version
of it.
Good starting point is the action bar compat
sample.
You can use a third-party library, like action
bar Sherlock.
Wait, there's also some good news, soon you
will be able to make the app-compat library
to make action bars that work all the way
to Eclair.
It will be as simple to use as support library's
fragments as well.
[ Applause ]
>>Adam Powell: Oh, would you --
>>> Yeah baby.
>>Adam Powell: Bruno, we made some friends.
Many of you familiar with backward compatible
fragments.
Action bars work the same way.
Action bar activity extends fragment activity
so you don't have to worry about any sort
of conflicts between those.
You will have fragments available as well.
And just like fetching the support fragment
manager, you can grab the support action bar
in the same way.
So the best part about this is the action
bar is really just the beginning of the kinds
of things that we are planning on making available
as part of the app-compat library.
Knowing all of these techniques we are talking
about today is always going to be useful but
really nobody likes code duplication.
We want to bring the common fruits of all
of this together in a form that you can just
simply include and use in your apps.
Bruno, actually it looks like we have time
left.
It's just enough time to talk about some miscellaneous
tips.
Now that we covered the most important topics.
Resource system themes, support app and app-compat
libraries.
So last we will finish up with some miscellaneous
tips that may be useful when writing multi-version
Android user interfaces.
Our first tip is to, by all means, resist
the temptation to style the options panel.
The options panel is one of those things that
the user sees as a familiar anchoring element.
If you make it look a lot different than what
the system looks like, that can be confusing
to users.
It's not difficult to confuse users.
Pay attention to the fact that each platform
version has different style.
Look at the options manual in options panel
in general.
So you should always provide assets to match
that style.
And try not to change it.
It's also worth noting that menu key is going
away.
Most new devices don't have a menu key.
Actually, most of the devices don't have hardware
keys at all.
>>Adam Powell: Some of them still do.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Some still do.
The menu key is definitely going away.
It's function has been replaced by action
overflow.
It's the same use case, when the user doesn't
find something on screen, they will look for
it in the menu key or in the action overflow,
depending on the system.
So remember, any action that follows the FIT
rule, or on your layout.
And then anything else should go either in
the options panel or in the action overflow
depending on the platform version.
Speaking about familiar anchoring elements.
That slide didn't come out too well.
Dialogues are also one of them.
The indicate system level interactions, like
critical yes or no prompts, they should be
used sparingly.
Because, as you can see, popups are very annoying.
Dialogues should never be a central part of
your user experience.
Leave them alone and don't change the default
style that they will take according to platform.
If for some reason you cannot resist the temptation
to style a dialogue, then this might be an
indication that whatever you're trying to
accomplish with that dialogue should not be
a dialogue at all.
It should be, in fact, part of your activity
or be a separate activity on its own.
By all means, never style dialogues.
So this next tip something that always drives
me crazy when I switch between devices maybe.
So on a pre-ICS device, the default button
order was positive, neutral, negative.
This is what we would typically see.
The button that does stuff is on the left.
And then the button that doesn't do anything,
that cancels, is on the right.
On Ice Cream Sandwich, we actually switched
them around.
So the button that does something is on the
right.
And the button that doesn't do anything is
on the left.
So it is better this way.
It is better -- the Ice Cream Sandwich way
is better because it reduces backtrack because
the option that the user is likely to choose
is closer to what the user is looking at when
he finishes reading the sentence.
You should always keep in mind that this is
different between platform releases.
If you want to go that extra mile in making
sure that your app is consistent with the
platform, you should always make sure that
your button order is consistent with whatever
platform you are running on so that you don't
surprise the user in a bad way.
>>Adam Powell: That's right.
This sort of button layout order issue is
the exactly the kind of thing we want to provide
in the app-compat library as well.
So we will go ahead and have some versioned
layouts that do the button bars.
And just as ad add note, some of you realized
that writing app that is use different themes
here, you might have noticed even on an Ice
Cream Sandwich device, an app that uses the
old style dialogue is still using the old
button order.
As it turns out, this is mostly because if
user become that familiar with that particular
application, not only do they have muscle
memory for it, but it's also fairly common
for applications to sort of mix and mingle
system-generated dialogues like an alert dialogue
with dialogues that they have a custom layout
for.
We didn't want to make individual apps internally
inconsistent with themselves for that.
So it is also important to keep in mind that
your app is not the only app that an user
is going to interact with on a daily basis.
So as you switch between different apps, you
do want to try to keep a level of consistency
with this sort of thing.
>>Bruno Oliveira: All right, our last hint.
Always set the minimum SDK version and target
SKD version in your manifest.
That's important because the minimum SDK should
be what it says, it's the minimum platform
version required to run your application.
Hopefully that's going to be as low as possible
and we hope that after this session it is
going to be even lower than before.
Now, the target SDK version is something that
many of us forget to set or they just set
to very old version.
So target SDK does not affect the minimum
SDK level needed to run your application.
So it should always be the latest platform
version that you are aware of and that you
have tested your application against.
So for everybody in Google I/O from this date,
this should be Jelly Bean.
This is important because depending on the
target SDK version, the platform is going
to enable or disable lots of compatibility
tricks, and that's going to affect things
like the default theme.
For instance, if you set your target SDK version
to 11 or above, you will have a default theme
that has an action bar.
If you don't, you will not get an action bar,
right?
And certain other features are also key to
that.
So if you want to make sure that you have
the latest features enabled for your application,
always set target SDK version as high as you
can.
Another example of that is if you set it to
a level 14 or above, you will get hard acceleration
by default on every activity.
If you don't, you will enable it individually
per activity.
So it's very important to set those two attributes
in your Android manifest.
>>Adam Powell: This is for safety in terms
of making sure that applications still run
even if we start making a little bit more
risky changes.
Hardware acceleration in UIs was definitely
one of these.
Not everything has the same performance profile
in hardware render, and there were certain
operations that weren't supported at all in
the beginning.
>>Bruno Oliveira: Remember, we don't want
to break anybody's application.
Backwards compatibility is one of the core
Android values.
This is why we have target SDK version.
Because this is how the platform knows what
your application expects to work with so we
can actually provide backwards compatibility
depending on the case.
>>Adam Powell: That's right.
>>Bruno Oliveira: So if anybody has any questions,
we would like to answer them now.
We also remind you that we have an office
hours space so anytime you want to ask a question,
you can drop by there.
We will go there right after this session.
If you have a more complex question or something
that requires us to see something, you can
-- we will be glad to talk to you there.
But so does anybody have any questions?
I think there are two microphones, right?
[ Applause ]
>>Bruno Oliveira: By the way, don't forget
we have plus one boxes at the corners of the
room.
so if you like the session -- if you like
our session, please put the plus one card
in.
We do not have minus cards.
If you don't like the session, you will have
to be old-fashioned and throw tomatoes, instead.
Just kidding.
Please don't throws vegetables whatsoever.
>>> I have a question about styles.
Like with the style buttons, like spinners,
so I tend to style everything to make the
app look same on Ice Cream Sandwich and Gingerbread.
Is that a good practice or not?
>>Adam Powell: If your app has a really distinctive
still of its own, yes, that can be a good
way to go.
I would also say that it's kind of a matter
of taste.
We're definitely sort of leaning toward more
holo styling in the Google apps.
The closer we get to that, the better.
>>> I found some Google apps running on the
Gingerbread, it looks like Ice Cream Sandwich.
With the spinner, on Google translate it looks
like Ice Cream Sandwich but spinner on Google,
I don't know.
>>Adam Powell: We definitely have a lot of
the Google apps that have taken some various
approaches to dealing with this.
And you'll find some different approaches
on each one.
It really does come down to how you want to
treat those older versions in the platform.
I would say it's a judgment call.
>>Bruno Oliveira: One thing for the action
bar, the action bar was not available before
Honeycomb.
Now it's a pretty apparent to have action
bars even though you are running on a device
running something prior to Honeycomb.
The action bar is one of those examples where
we sort of like back ported a pattern to previous
versions.
>>> Quick question.
Any recommendation how to integrate Google
Maps with fragment.
>>Adam Powell: That's a fun one.
Do you want to take this one?
>>Bruno Oliveira: The problem with is that
when you are using support library you have
to arrive from fragment activity.
When you are arriving from Google Maps, you
have to derive from map activity.
One of the problems with languages that don't
have multiple inheritances, you can't do that
in an obvious way.
We don't currently have a way that you can
do that.
So you are just going to have to branch and
if you are running -- if you need the support
library, you can just use that in some different
way and just have a regular activity, not
a fragment activity.
And then derive from map activity.
If not, you derive from map activity.
There is no -- currently no way to do that
except branching.
>>Adam Powell: That is and isn't true.
There's actually a couple of really dirty
tricks that you can pull that technically
work and if you'd like to talk more about
those, see me in office hours after we are
done here.
>>> Hi, does the new action bar activity support
some of the additional action bar functionality
found in Honeycomb and Ice Cream Sandwich
similar to, like, the alternate action bar.
I forget the name after it.
>>Adam Powell: Split bar.
>>> To replace the top action bar or Gmail
the action bar at the bottom?
>>Adam Powell: To replace?
I'm not sure which you are talking about.
The split bar that you see in Gmail or talking
about the one that replaces the current bar
for the action modes?
>>> Both.
>>Adam Powell: Both.
The split bar, yes, that will be there.
The action modes, no, they won't.
The action mode API is set up that it's series
of calls at the view level that basically
bubble up the hierarchy and get dealt with
as you go up.
We really don't have a good way of expressing
that there.
It's always not a pattern that was -- it really
wasn't supported pattern prior to that either,
so I would say that the way to adapt across
that boundary when you have a case where you
want to use multiple selection action mode
on newer platforms, but you kind of wonder
what to do on an old one, I would say use
a context menu.
>>> Thank you.
>>> (inaudible)
>>Adam Powell: Cool, we will take a look at
it
>>> Action bar Sherlock, using that on a Google
TV, it nicely puts the action bar on top.
Will compatibility library do the same?
Or will it be on the side?
>>Adam Powell: For Google TV?
The plan is on the top.
>>> Thank you.
>>Adam Powell: By the way, regarding action
bar Sherlock, is Jake here by any chance?
Oh, nuts, okay.
>>> Where is the best place to learn about
at compat and what's going on with it.
>>Adam Powell: Stay tuned, there will be an
Android developer post on it.
>>> I have a similar question on fragment
in the support library.
>>Adam Powell: This is going to be another
fun one.
Go ahead.
>>> Is it going to be integrated?
>>Adam Powell: Preference -- oh, I see, so
preference fragments in the support library?
We will take a look at it.
There haven't been direct plans as far as
I know, but we will see what we can do.
>>> Before we had -- there was somebody talking
about the fact that we are implementing right
to left text as -- inversed, too.
>>Adam Powell: Has which been inversed?
>>> Inversed, right to left, right to left
text.
>>Bruno Oliveira: I'm pretty sure that they
are.
I'm pretty sure they follow the language setting.
>>Adam Powell: The stuff that's been going
in so far bidirectional support has been fairly
deep.
It's also something that we tried to do more
or less automatically.
I would say you could probably expect anything
that's in app-compat around button bar styles
like that will be pretty much automatic, but
I don't think that -- I'm trying to think
if that's something that's -- backporting
makes a whole lot of sense for.
At the point where you start backporting all
of the bidirectional layout type stuff, you
are essentially replacing half the UI tool
kit.
>>> Any plans to provide more adapters besides
SDK adapter regarding fragments?
>>Adam Powell: I don't think I understand
the question.
The listed app?
>>> For instance, there is a fragment listed
app but there is no for gridview or for any
other views?
>>Adam Powell: Fragment list adapter.
A list fragment?
>>> Yes.
>>Adam Powell: I see.
I suppose we could add them.
But I think the list fragment was more meant
to be there as little bit of parity with the
list activity that we had before.
That is something extraordinary simple.
It has been farther down the priority list.
We have wanted to handle the more complex
cases out of the box first.
We can certainly take a look at it.
>>> Fragments in fragments.
There's a common case where you have an action
bar with a navigation list.
Depending what you choose, you put it in fragments
in and out.
But the problem is what if you are using something
like a view pager and you have a view pager
fragment?
How do you deal with that?
I know there are work-around.
Is there any way we can get it done normally?
>>Adam Powell: Most of the times when I have
taken a look deeper into some of these cases,
it generally means there's something kind
of weird about the layout to begin with.
We generally don't really want to support
fragments in fragments right now.
It's come up over and over and it sounds like
a good idea; sounds like a bad idea.
Sounds like a good idea; sounds like a bad
idea.
We go back and forth.
A lot of times when it comes to the view pager
specifically, what we usually end up doing
is -- this is a case where I wish I had a
white board.
If you want to come down to the office hours
later to do more, that's great.
But I will try to wrap it up.
Generally what we will try and do, if you
have something like a two-pane layout where
you have a list and view pager off to the
side, then at some point you have like a top
level skeleton that is sort of where all the
fragments go, right?
So it's essentially your top level layout.
In a case like that, conceptually the view
pager is part of that skeleton.
You can kind of thing of the fragments that
the view pager brings in and out as being
on the same level as that side bar list itself.
So in those cases, the view pager would actually
be part of the top level lay out and not in
a fragment on its own.
It would manage the internal fragments itself
and that avoids the need for nesting.
>>> Okay.
But you are aware of, though, the work-arounds
where people have to load -- set the adapters
for the view pager in a separate handler just
to avoid the exception that comes up?
>>Bruno Oliveira: I have never seen that.
>>Adam Powell: Which exception?
I think this might be something a little bit
different.
>>> Maybe I will talk about it --
>>Adam Powell: Come see me in the office hours
afterwards.
I'm interested.
Is that all?
>>Bruno Oliveira: Any more questions?
>>Adam Powell: One more.
>>> There used to be an expandable list activity.
Is there any plans to, like, pull the expandable
list fragment into the app compatibility as
well.
There are open source implementations out
there.
Is there anything you are going to look at
that?
>>Adam Powell: If there are contributions
to AOSP.
If there are implementations that are Apache
2 that someone would like to submit.
>>> It is on (indiscernible) android.com with
the snippet.
>>Adam Powell: Is there?
Great.
We will take a look at that time.
In terms of taking code snippets pasted into
the bug tracker, that ends up being problematic
for us.
It needs to be loaded into AOSP for that sort
of thing.
>>> Sure, we can take a look at that.
>>Adam Powell: Is that it?
>>Bruno Oliveira: Thank you very much.
>>Adam Powell: Thank you all.